sie glauben sie wüssten wie die welt
funktioniert
sie sind ein mann der die welt wie durch
ein schlüsselloch sieht aber was wenn
ich ihnen sage dass diese realität nur
eine von vielen ist es trends ist der
neueste spielfilm mtu im marvel universe
das ist der versuch dieses komplizierte
universum der marvel comic superhelden
comics ins kino zu übertragen doctor
strange ist wahrscheinlich die
schwierigste dieser übertragung weil man
sich nicht so ohne weiteres anders
orientieren kann was verfilmbar ist da
ein großer teil der handlung von doctor
strange auf der s top player also in
eine andere dimension in einer anderen
art welt stattfindet die solistischen 8
nutzen sie die energie um die realität
zu formen
dass die geschichte von einem
neurochirurgen der seine hände verliert
der vorher ziemlich arrogant ist sehr
gut ist in seinem fach und danach glaubt
zu nichts mehr nütze zu sein dann
irgendwann zu einem weisheits lehrer in
diesem fall in dem film seiner weisheit
lehrerin geht die im östlichen medizin
beibringen soll die ihm da helfen soll
in wirklichkeit wird ihm aber die
mystische kunst erschlossen das heißt er
wird zum magier sie denken sie
durchschauen mich tun sie ja nicht aber
ich durchschaue da für sie ich fand das
von allen großen maul figuren die wir
bis jetzt im kino gesehen haben mit der
ausnahme vielleicht von captain america
das eigentlich die figur mit dem größten
spalt drin und das hat mir sehr gut
gefallen und ich natürlich auch wieder
an nolan erinnert nämlich in dem fall
ist nicht an inception wie die visuelle
welt sondern an christian bales
interpretation von batman er genau durch
so ein teil muss was war denn sie wird
südlichen er ist es ist nur mit etwas wo
nicht der witz dabei ist das eben
stiftet kozo in den frühen sechzigern
als der comic erfunden wurde sich da was
ausgedacht hat visuell das eigentlich
reduziert werden muss um es ins 3d kino
zu bringen
alleiniges 5d nicht alles was energie du
hast du zu sagen nicht das was
normalerweise bei fantastic oder
superhelden gegeben ist im mcu nämlich
eine einigermaßen vertraute welt new
york was auch immer sondern die welt
selber wackelt die ganze zeit die welt
selber dreht sich die welt selber
krempelt sich von innen nach außen und
in diesen comics die disco gezeichnet
hat ist es halt so dass du teilweise
nicht mal mehr weißt was eigentlich
bildvordergrund und bildhintergrund ist
weil irgendwelche tropfenden häuser das
halt sehr erschweren und ich finde der
film hat eine sehr schöne lösung
gefunden da für diese sehr schwierige
sache zu visualisieren nämlich die anker
sind in diesem fall einfach die
schauspieler hör karibik ist kein marvel
film bis jetzt besetzt gewesen was leute
angeht die einfach einen ruf haben als
charakterdarsteller tilda swinton spielt
die engine brawn gp vor ist warum morde
ein anderer schüler mads mikkelsen ist
der widersacher und benedict cumberbatch
ist doctor strange das heißt das sind
alles leute die können auch telefonbuch
spielen
darüber hinaus kommt noch was dazu was
in den doctor strange comics jedenfalls
in den frühen überhaupt nicht drin ist
nämlich humor was ist das mein mantra
das wlan passwort
wir sind keine wegen also insgesamt ein
film der die erwartungen erfüllen kann
die hohe erwartung dann haben weil sie
das quellenmaterial kennen und
diejenigen auf eine interessante art
verwirren kann die das quellenmaterial
nicht kennen